Estas son algunas de las decisiones reales que ha tomado la IA muy recientemente,
basada en los prejuicios que ha aprendido de nosotros,
de los humanos.
La IA se usa para ayudar a decidir si reciben o no esa entrevista de trabajo,
cuánto pagan por el seguro del auto,
cuán bueno es su historial de crédito,
e incluso qué calificación reciben en su revisión anual de desempeño.
Pero estas decisiones se filtran a través
de sus supuestos sobre nuestra identidad, nuestra raza, nuestro sexo, nuestra edad.
¿Cómo ocurre eso?
Ahora imaginen que la IA está ayudando a un gerente de contrataciones
a encontrar el siguiente líder de tecnología para la compañía.
Hasta ahora el gerente ha estado contratando mayormente hombres.
Entonces, la IA aprende que es más probable
que los programadores sean hombres, en vez de mujeres.
Y de ahí hay un estrecho muy corto hasta:
"los hombres son mejores programadores que las mujeres".
Hemos reforzado nuestros propios prejuicios en la IA.
Y ahora elimina a las candidatas femeninas.
Si un gerente de contratación humano hiciera eso
estaríamos indignados, no lo permitiríamos.
Este tipo de discriminación por el sexo no está bien.
Y, sin embargo, de algún modo, la IA se ha situado sobre la ley,
ya que una máquina tomó la decisión.
No solo eso.
Estamos reforzando también nuestro prejuicio en cómo interactuamos con la IA.
¿Cuán a menudo usan un asistente de voz como Siri, Alexa o incluso Cortana?
Ellos tienen dos cosas en común:
una, nunca pueden captar bien mi nombre,
y segundo, todas son femeninas.
Están designadas para ser nuestros sirvientes obedientes,
que encienden y apagan nuestras luces, que encargan nuestra compra.
También hay una IA masculina, pero tiende a tener más poder,
como IBM Watson, que toma decisiones de negocios,
Salesforce Einstein o ROSS, el robot abogado.
Así que, pobres robots, incluso ellos sufren el sexismo en el trabajo.
(Risas)
Piensen en cómo se combinan estas dos cosas
y en cómo afectan a un niño que crece en el mundo de hoy, con la IA.
Por ejemplo, hacen una investigación para un proyecto escolar
y buscan en Google imágenes de directores generales.
El algoritmo les muestra una mayoría de hombres como resultado.
Y ahora buscan en Google "asistente personal".
Como se imaginarán, les muestra una mayoría de mujeres.
Y luego ellos quieren poner algo de música y quizás encargar algo de comida,
y dan órdenes, gritando, a una asistente de voz femenina.
Algunas de nuestras mentes más brillantes están creando hoy en día esta tecnología.
Una tecnología que podrían haber creado del modo que quisieran.
Y, sin embargo, eligieron crearla al estilo
de la secretaria de "Mad Men" de los años 50.
¡Yey!
Pero no se preocupen,
no voy a terminar diciéndoles
que vamos rumbo hacia que las máquinas sexistas y racistas dominen el mundo.
La buena noticia sobre la IA es que está completamente bajo nuestro control.
Tenemos que enseñarle a la IA los valores correctos, la ética correcta.
Y podemos hacer tres cosas.
Una, podemos ser conscientes de nuestros propios prejuicios
y de los prejuicios en las máquinas a nuestro alrededor.
Dos, podemos asegurarnos de que equipos heterogéneos construyan esta tecnología.
Y tres, debemos brindarle experiencias diferentes para que aprenda.
Desde mi experiencia personal puedo hablar sobre las dos primeras.
Cuando trabajas en tecnología
y no te pareces a Mark Zuckerberg o Elon Musk,
tu vida es un poco difícil, cuestionan tu capacidad.
Este es un ejemplo.
Como muchos desarrolladores, a menudo entro en foros tecnológicos en línea
y comparto mis conocimientos para ayudar a otros.
Y he encontrado
que cuando accedo como yo, con mi foto y mi nombre,
tiendo a recibir preguntas o comentarios como este:
"¿Qué te hace pensar que estás cualificada para hablar sobre IA?".
"Qué te hace pensar que sabes sobre el aprendizaje automático?".
Así que, como Uds. lo harían, hice un nuevo perfil de Internet,
y esta vez, en lugar de mi foto, elegí un gato con una mochila propulsora.
Y elegí un nombre que no revelara mi sexo.
Pueden imaginarse a qué conduce esto, ¿no?
Esta vez no recibí ninguno de estos comentarios despectivos sobre mi capacidad
y pude lograr algunas cosas.
Y esto apesta, chicos.
He estado construyendo robots desde los 15 años,
tengo algunos títulos en informática
y, sin embargo, tengo que esconder mi sexo
para que tomen en serio mi trabajo.
Entonces, ¿qué es lo que ocurre aquí?
¿Los hombres son mejores que las mujeres en cuanto a la tecnología?
Otro estudio descubrió
que cuando las mujeres que hacen código en una plataforma también ocultaron su sexo,
su código fue aceptado un 4 % más que el de los hombres.
Así que no es cuestión de talento.
Se trata de un elitismo en la IA
que dice que un programador debe tener cierto aspecto.
Lo que debemos hacer realmente para mejorar la IA
es atraer a personas con orígenes variados.
Necesitamos gente que pueda escribir y contar historias
para ayudarnos a crear las personalidades de la IA.
Necesitamos gente capaz de resolver problemas.
Necesitamos gente que enfrente desafíos diferentes
y que nos digan cuáles son los problemas reales que necesitan resolverse
y que nos ayuden a encontrar los modos en que la tecnología puede resolverlos.
Porque cuando las personas de distintos orígenes se unen,
cuando construimos las cosas del modo correcto,
las posibilidades son ilimitadas.
Y eso es de lo que finalmente quiero hablarles.
Menos robots racistas, menos máquinas que tomarán nuestros trabajos...
y más sobre lo que la tecnología puede lograr.
Así que, sí, algo de la energía en el mundo de la IA,
en el mundo de la tecnología
estará dirigida hacia la publicidad que ven cuando están en Internet.
Pero mucho de ella se dirigirá a hacer que el mundo sea mucho mejor.
Piensen en una mujer embarazada en la República Democrática del Congo,
que debe caminar 17 horas hasta la clínica rural prenatal más cercana
para hacerse una revisión médica.
¿Y si en lugar de eso ella pudiera obtener un diagnóstico por teléfono?
O piensen en lo que la IA podría hacer
por esa mujer de cada tres en Sudáfrica
que sufre la violencia doméstica.
Si fuera peligroso hablar en voz alta,
ella podría tener un servicio de IA para lanzar la alarma,
para obtener ayuda financiera y legal.
Estos son ejemplos de proyectos reales que la gente, incluyéndome a mí,
está trabajando ahora, empleando la IA.
Así que estoy segura de que en los próximos días habrá otra noticia
sobre el riesgo existencial,
robots tomando el control y tomando sus trabajos.
(Risas)
Y cuando pase algo como eso,
se que recibiré los mismos mensajes de preocupación con respecto al futuro.
Pero me siento muy positiva con respecto a esta tecnología.
Esta es nuestra oportunidad de hacer el mundo un lugar más igualitario.
Pero para hacerlo debemos construirlo del modo correcto desde el principio.
Necesitamos personas de distintos sexos, razas, sexualidades y orígenes.
Necesitamos que las mujeres sean hacedoras,
y no solo las máquinas que sigan las órdenes de los hombres.
Debemos pensar muy cuidadosamente lo que le enseñamos a las máquinas,
los datos que les damos,
de modo que no repitan nuestros errores pasados.
Espero dejarlos pensando en dos cosas.
Primero, espero dejarlos pensando en los prejuicios.
Y la próxima vez que vean una publicidad en Internet
que asume que están interesados en clínicas de fertilidad
o en sitios web de apuestas en línea,
que piensen y recuerden
que la misma tecnología asume que un hombre negro será reincidente;
o que es más probable que una mujer sea una asistente personal y no una directora.
Y espero que les recuerde que debemos hacer algo sobre eso.
Y segundo,
espero que piensen sobre el hecho
de que no necesitan tener un cierto aspecto
o tener una cierta formación en ingeniería o tecnología
para crear IA,
lo que será una fuerza fenomenal para nuestro futuro.
No necesitan ser parecidos a Mark Zuckerberg,
pueden parecerse a mí.
Y depende de todos Uds. en esta sala
poder convencer a los gobiernos y las corporaciones
para que construyan una IA para todos,
incluso los casos marginales.
Y que todos nos eduquemos en el futuro
sobre esta tecnología fenomenal.
Porque si hacemos eso,
habremos arañado la superficie de lo que podemos lograr con la IA.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)